breaking news terror in France it has
happened again the joy of normal life
becomes a nightmare in seconds that was
the scene in Nice France last night
Frances and France will always be
stronger
I assure you fealty clan the fanatics we
pledge to stand with our French friends
as we defend our nation's against this
scourge of terrorism and violence we are
also thinking of our friends in France
where last night more than 80 people
including many children were killed in a
terrorist attack in Nice almost 8 months
to the day terrorists strike France once
again 89 people lost their lives on
November 13th at the badeck LAN now 84
innocent lives including 10 children
were taken as celebrations were underway
for Bastille Day disbelief anger and
sadness prayers quickly spread across
social media with the hashtag pray for
nice trending worldwide what's happening
in this world
pray for nice tweeted Chloe grace Moretz
enough pray for nice said Amy Schumer
Leonardo DiCaprio writes my heart goes
out to the victims and families of nice
we stand with everyone in France in
liberté égalité a fraternity while
Gabrielle Union says it never ends
heartbroken pray for nice just hours
before the attack
Rihanna posted an Instagram video of how
amazing and joyful her European tour was
going she was scheduled to perform
tonight but instead uploaded this photo
of a heart-shaped French flag due to the
tragic events in Nice my concert
scheduled for tomorrow July 15th at
Allianz Stadium will not be going ahead
as planned our thoughts are with the
victims and their families both Jamie
Dornan and Dakota Johnson are also in
France as production on the Fifty Shades
of Grey sequel gets underway a producer
of the film says she doesn't expect
filming to stop and took to her Facebook
page to give fans an update production
has confirmed that everyone working on
location in the South of France is OK
everyone has been accounted for and is
safe and sound thanks for everyone's
messages and concerns
another sad day for France and the world